[Musique]
on va démarrer le premier chant avec
jean michel maire jean michel maire vous
avez remis à chanter il va chanter en
karaoké
mettez-vous la merci isabelle jean
michel maire vous avez démarré à chanter
et vous allez chanter d'autres chansons
d'accord jean michel vous avez vous avez
vous allez chanter quoi on dirait dhamir
on dirait d'avenir qui a été élue
chanson de l'année on embrasse à venir
c'est pas trop les paroles alors je vais
vous dire et puis les crochets nice à
lyon vous qui l'avez compris un peu le
premier oui j'allais chez jean-michel
verte et là il va chanter pendant qu'il
chante je vais appeler un ami à moi qui
s'appelle youssef et il va voom assez
d'accord vous devez continuer à chanter
non ça va j'ai lépaule un peu les gars
hier soir je suis venu chez vous à 4h30
du matin vous étiez où j'étais à
l'extérieur on va en parler tout à
l'heure à l'est pour l'instant c'est
parti vous allez chanter c'est vous
c'est la fête c'est parti on y va au
delà
sans toi tu es là là là qu'on dirait
qu'on a tous un enjeu l'on dirait on
dirait bien que c'est toi qu'on dirait
dans ce monde étrange on dirait d'atouts
la droite est la seule qui voit la
beauté cachée des visages tout tourne
autour de toi à toi tu sais lire en moi
promet c'est bon c'est pas mal merci à
tous la victime est le meilleur sauteur
[Applaudissements]
journal évoque le peter paul tu vas tous
les voir et que nous dira pour toi qui
étais le meilleur chanteur siet tu as le
même que les téléspectateurs tu gagnes
la tablette tactile on va demander
maintenant à mon ami jean luc lemoine de
bien vouloir vieillir jantes et parce
que ces jeux pas d'où cette fois je
n'entends pas dieu cf vous vous vous
c'est pas le masquer et vous allez
devoir changer de perruques toutes les
cinq secondes
allez vous ne décidez vous démarrez
qu'une perruque dupouy d'avesnes peru
vous retourner cette année on démarre
attention c'est au bal masqué on vous
l'avait commencée cottin la chanson
attention c'est parti à 2,3
dans cette audience au bal masqué c'est
mon bonheur c'est mon bonheur
hautmont voit pas pendant toute l'année
on prépare les costumes casanova
respecter les coutumes cendrillon la
pole et aujourd'hui je vois ce qu'il me
plaît 2000 et 2001 2000 et qui je suis
merci bonjour mieux valu que moi
l'inculpé rues sales halimi tient que
lou mais tout me va rebondir et de
julian perretta c'était ça et entre je
viens de perdre à étirer moreau ouais si
ça va bien il ya quelque chose
attention un paul tu as trouvé comment
la prestation de jean luc tu as préféré
me jean-luc ou jean-michel pour
l'instant abba battant largement jean
luc ackaert jean michel c'est pas de
vols qua non pareillement en revanche
assez d'accord ils n'ont qu'a pu si la
date est ce que vous qu'est ce que vous
allez chanter libérer des lits vrai mais
je sens que c'est très loin
la reine des neiges d'accord j'adore le
nez même fait une de mes chansons
préférées
capucine comme voulant chanter la reine
des neiges intense et la glace c'est la
neige est bien pendant que vous
chanterez vous resterez concentré vous
inquiétez pas elle s est concentré
attention c'est parti on y va on y va le
bien le match dit tant pis libéré
des toits le temps des lévres à libérer
[Musique]
robert maire de givet
allez c'est parti
libéré capucine magnifique cheval
s'était libérée des livres et c'est
normal le suisse est tout à fait leur
attitude quand tu la trouves épaules je
suis fait à la c'est très bien taquet
attention isabelle morini-bosc c'est
tabou alors alors vous devez chanter je
crois que j'avais chanté chaud cacao
d'annie cordy
ouais ok c'est une question de
génération vous allez devoir et d'en
prendre une cuillère de chocolat en
poudre sac tout les sacs jaunes je vous
la donnerais d'accord moi j'ai horreur
de chocolat baye fall for mac est déjà
les noms qui sont jaunes à cause du café
vous êtes vraiment on sent que vous
m'aimez vous en a pas merci merci madame
on ne peut plus originale pour les
gamins j'en peux plus plus tôt tu vas tu
dis un truc bavaisis pluie tout vu que
c'est juste que je mens le fond de ma
pensée balesi payet il ya des enfants
qui nous regarde bien dans l'idée on y
est tu vois un je peux faire avec les
doigts je vois rien je suis avec la
lèche à deux doigts de craquer allez
c'est parti ou débat et moi donc
[Musique]
je veux amener d'autres comme moi dans
ce cas là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si tu n'aimes des noix de coco moi je te
donnerai ma cac 40
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voici pourquoi ces personnes
ma
alors vol les voleurs il a été
fantastique elle avait vaincu bravo
belle mère je sais qu'à pita qu il part
maintenant aller jacquouille à des
calories les messieurs vega aller et
nous avons 35 non alors on s'est dit on
va en faire une petite dernière
je ne peux nier dernière alors il ya il
nous reste quoi parce que hawaii nous
resterons à jamais si gilles les lapins
et il a vu que ça ne lui parle plus
gilles verdez gilles verdez comme un
ouragan et on va installer à l'ouragan
pour vous c'est parti vous chantez vous
donner tous attention c'est parti
[Musique]
emprisonne tourbillonne comme un ouragan
qui passait sur moi l'amour à tout en
pole
c'est comme un ouragan qui passait sur
moi sa mort a cependant fait passer sur
moi la cour ajoute on pourra donc y
passer par mucha tout en français
[Musique]
l'ouragan a laissé mon merci c'est bon
merci au peuple bien gilbert des lois
baba les blessés du lait on sait que ces
gars c'est quoi ces de la crème solaire
phase accord serait bien merci
alors les divisions après chef un trou
est pâle et avec lou paul paul mon chéri
vole mon chéri à ton avis qui a gagné 2
non non non dis moi les deux que tu
préférais me labelle et jean luc ayé
géniaux alors il avait les gens lui qui
en a une qui est finaliste alors dit
nous à ton avis qui a été la meilleure
ou le meilleur dirai quand je reviens
qui gens du que j'ai quand même dire
isabelle d'autres cas d'accord ouais
parce que je tenais une donc tu des
lycées peut-être est un indice est bien
la préférée des téléspectateurs a été 9e
capucines à l'avs qui a gagné car plus
ils troquent 100%
bravo mme aka plus à l'amour chérie tu
as perdu mais tu gagnes quand même la
table est acquis c'est l'été il reste
trois émissions à civelli pacy-vallée
bon je déclare yves ranger mon métier
pas la jouer serré on va se retrouver
tout de suite j'ai rien dit
[Applaudissements]
silence la pub match là on va se
retrouver dans l'instant sur le plateau
central est la police
g